whatup guys finally caught up on
dailyvee we had a ton in the can I'm
sure you've noticed but now we are
finally back on track with a levy caught
up to date this is from two days ago
we're back in our cadence 2019 swags I
hope you enjoy it I want to give away
all my marketing advice for free and
don't care if I get a penny for it which
then leads me to get pennies for it you
got your prospectus
[Music]
yo
how are you I can let's rock and roll
everybody's in short term bro everybody
wants us like like do you know that 95%
of people listening here try to do
social media but after 1 to 4 months
they gave up because they didn't see a
sale from it because 99% of people when
they do social media are trying to take
steroids people don't get it man people
are just so hungry for short-term
affirmation that they're willing to
undermine their long term success
[Music]
and 99% of people's social media
behavior is selfish
99% of people listening to this right
now only care about selling a home
not actually educating somebody how to
get a better home do you know why I'm
one of the most followed people because
I want to give away all my marketing
advice for free and don't care if I get
a penny for it which then leads me to
get pennies for it
[Music]
[Music]
you just have to document documentary
doesn't come natural to everybody
because everybody thinks what they do is
boring they don't realize its unique
that's what works
reality TV works like people want to see
what's happening in people's lives if
you know if you have nothing to say you
have the documentation of your day I
mean the themes are just reverse
engineering the audience right like how
do we bring more value tactically is
really what I'm focused on right like if
you're not going to agent 2021 and not
realizing modern digital execution is
what you're there for now it's about the
details you know more QA more deeper
expertise of technicians who've executed
in mortgage or real estate or things
that nature so just more more depth of
detail linked in long-form creative to
build expertise or podcast to be the
commercial real estate expert of a
region I couldn't get people more to be
understand that they have to become
media personalities or entities spit out
all their expertise and then use that
leverage to garnish business you know an
article on LinkedIn is five seconds away
from going viral that's called what
seven things you need to look out for
when you open your second location and
if you're the one that wrote it and I
read it because I'm opening my second
Wine Library because I live on LinkedIn
and Facebook like everybody else does
whether you're 8 or 88 and then I see
that you're actually a commercial real
estate person I might just message you
from LinkedIn and now that article led
to me using you this is happening every
day brother this is happening in b2b
software sales this is happening in real
estate this is happening in politics
like I just I'm fascinated by people not
willing to put in the work out of
laziness or success the people that are
winning right now are in the middle are
in the middle ironically you're you got
the people to the left that are just
lazy and they don't wanna put in the
work they hear me but they don't to put
it work and then you have a group of
people who are so successful right now
they don't think they're in trouble
I think the veterans that I know you
know and I know a lot of them are more
interested in just selling off their
reputation and when they hear me talk
they're like yeah that's cool but like
I'm the queen bee in Malibu everybody
knows who I am
I don't need Gary's bullcrap of like
putting in Instagram it doesn't matter
it's gonna like I don't want to put out
social because I'm I'm like high-end or
they just come up with excuses because
they can still get away with it but
here's what they don't realize on the
next downturn on the economic crisis
which is inevitable when the Phoenix
rises it's gonna be all the 26 year olds
that built brand during this era and
then they won't be the queen bee anymore
they're gonna be the has-been but the
problem is they're not ready to retire
[Music]
dude I love you for like setting that up
like everybody's faking like I'd much
rather see you do your listings in a
Toyota that has like a bum tire cuz it's
your truth like if you're faking the
Maserati and the top and the $5,000 suit
what do you do when I run into you at
the restaurant you don't have to fake it
to you make it everybody in real estate
and sales everyone's trying to posture
wearing a suit this and that like
literally renting a limousine or a
Lamborghini I mean everybody's faking
bro I was like go tell the truth like
tell the truth of your journey document
don't you have nothing to say all you
have to say is the documentation of the
journey of becoming a real estate agent
then people start getting into you out
of your authenticity and truth and then
in 3 years you might be able to start
actually getting the results of that now
if somebody listening here are 17 years
in the business what she or he can do is
tell put out content about things that
they know are tried-and-true mistake
nobody's bringing the reason I would
dominate real estate is I would just
give away the secrets I'd be like lo
here's the things that you need to look
out for here's where people get caught
on taxes here's where people get caught
on on inspections here's what you need
to think about when you're merchandising
cinnamon cookies do this candles do that
I would literally do what I'm doing with
marketing and what I did with wine why
have I been able to over index in both
things that I've done I gave away all
the truths all the industry secrets I
opened up the kimono in the wine world
this isn't worth it this is worth it
this is what you should pay for want to
get better in wine try different things
why am i dominating in marketing I put
out 86 page slides that people charge
five thousand dollars for is an e-book
and I put it away for free and daily I
put away content for free and then I
tell people don't listen to me watch me
so if I'm doing this you do that and
that's why there's tens of thousands of
people who've made a lot of money or
found a lot of happiness on the back of
my content yep yep there's a wide open
space in the real estate industry
because everybody's short-term selfish
figure out how to be
long term giving and watch your business
grow in 2022 thank you brother
talk to you